[Music]
hi my name is Jennifer Martinez and I
just finished a talk involving this
crazy headset on my head this is a
headset that repeat EEG or your
brainwaves and it's made by a company
called a modem and so I took this
headset and I put it on my husband and I
asked him a series of questions and
first I had you to tell me the truth and
then I asked him to lie to me and what
that gives me is a label data set of
what his brainwaves look like needs
telling the truth and what they look
like when he's lying and so I took that
data embedded into a machine learning
algorithm to build a classifier to
perform lie detection so for great
content like this in other really fun
part come join us at NBC in locations
all over the world
London Oslo Sydney and other it's so
much fun you'll be some amazing people
learned some really incredible
technology and have a great time join us
you
[Music]